she got a chance of moti the
aforementioned and here's Cameron in the
final reminiscing and Gantt challenge by
Davis and ahead it comes holidays at
Davidson all evening
four seconds woody a down the lane
blocked by Davis this is the isolation
that you rarely see and dr. Knox
Davis Jax will all give the world a
little water but he'll chase it down
second block of the B
[Applause]
this guy have and he was an economical
signing officer he led with the block
watch out later last season that is
incredible and we saw drew sizing it up
before it's Gortat second block of the
game for a Dean is first four and a half
minutes of play at the rim here another
concerning of five blocks make it six
for the first quarter where the defense
has struggled they did not tip it tool
visually it's it's only his first Joe
Harris
[Applause]
you know where they want to go in
isolation ball mills and block for
Anthony Davis they are with that bucket
is yet nine boys
Zach Lavine you're right 19 points but
kids required 18 shots and it's his 31
good to see him just healthy
[Music]
a second
protected b14 more you can see them just
talk in that block right there better
trying to stay in front a letter they D
comes over well time to the block and if
I can stop it get the B Danny Green is
going the other way with the charge
anyone assists already for the
Timberwolves in this half t as 11 of
them down to one second and t gets
emphatically denied by Davis at the horn
and plus assists a game
that's great good to pledge my heritage
but
and beat on a clear-out and take it away
just strip clean block by Davis this is
where she wants
[Applause]
trying to get by be blocked away from
behind by ad C but it goes right to
drill on it to jump by Anthony and maybe
it's something to do with that Oprah
locked away we saw that coming
not tip Fraser fatwa Julius Randle to
the rim dropping dimes no sir to the
bells second and the league of the story
Richardson body was free to the rim
didn't he just tracking it spin by
Richardson on the probe holiday dragging
up well that's pretty good eighties
there to clean it up blocking third
block McGruder are the reverse which and
Winslow they won't get it
this defense is top five with him in the
game it's better just a blue through
there then Harold's tripped up and he
stays with it but ad-hoc blows through
and that's the length of Kyle Anderson -
don't forget true tried to jump the rats
instead Noah blocks away
[Applause]
- right Jin I can erase some mistakes
like that - holiday all over Reggie
Jackson of the screen roll with Brooke
and now it's Robin locked away from
behind secondary defender Anthony Davis
second in the league in blocked shots
Randall
he's got holidays spacing squaring
Heather gives it away
[Applause]
and he cleans it up
after the turnover minute thirteen to
play eight-point game you can see this
all the way Bledsoe
babies in the neighborhood had his shot
blocked at the rim like this last night
and the response to that is either way
you're on the poster yeah either plus
seven in the quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
dials deny he saw that coming a half
hour away now minutes of play Matthews
still trying to get there and AD cleans
it up and saves it big-time play on the
baseline now the bells
they've got points last for maybe the
last five possessions excellent
eight-point game
Dennis Smith jr. the Andre doesn't want
it that far for the basket but you got
it you gotta see ad with the rejection
comes up with it Santa Manila on the run
[Applause]
go to the free-throw line get our energy
power play well that's suffice for now
block shot you don't quit on the play
second effort and then
this certainly can't go like this their
best hat but they're battling and
they're staying right here keeping it
within striking distance and making
plays like that maybe against the blocks
there's Brussels one on one to Harris
baseline drive Paris
ad with the rejection the cut by Moore
and the flip goes down they only an 88
David to your point the landscape will
the give and go
temple blocked away into the shot clock
campaign time did put speed nothing was
available at the corner fence rising to
take a shot all three good breaks
AET cleans it up third block of the game
for Anthony before watch him he locked
up with Noah here this comes off and
grape recovery final shot for
Dellavedova and the Cavs Clarkson
[Applause]
and to the quarter paintable kind of it
goes so 13 is the deficit it could have
been worse had it not been for the guy
that second a little you gonna block
shots blocked and it and they're done
because this is a great block the area
which he covered to get there and then
his body falls out of bounds and he
stays with it no sir Myron Wallace came
onto the floor out of the timeout into
the shot clock blue on a good move
there's your rim protection zone here of
Kogi dishes to Gibson trying to find
space could not Davis the block and the
gather the pelicans can jump in front
here Frazier gives it to try to get it
back to towns does towns lost it
[Applause]
that's some block right there
it's out of six and a half to play but
CJ Miles is finding ways to get open
it's not a doctor way by
a lot of time on the shot clock with
discovery the look there will be a great
look by his standards
[Music]
nobody's not the ball ad protects the
rim
[Applause]
[Applause]
she meets about top he's got the block
read it from the I times it perfectly
that never gets old it'll be Cambridge
Williams felon up for three he have read
that twenty new Kendrick has been ten
rich had been beat he goes and makes the
play touch pass back to it
bigoted leftist that's all they do is
they try to trade through lefties around
here entry for Sean Thomas
[Music]
secondary defenders beautiful blocks
just to ten shooting so far Derrick
Favors quiet enters 23 at 18 angle
clocked away but can't hold on got the
entry ad time to got the block took care
ago bear there on the reach favors and
Alfred's go bear rotation and he's one
of the best at this coming with Rawls
help getting blocked shots that way
never gonna win down that hit their last
three after missing six straight now
Bazemore on the run and Anthony Davis
into the popcorn stand place to come get
a win don't doesn't matter
this team is mine Tony Snell what it
look like automatic up to the top of the
glass we won 112 108 here hardik ad
Spike's it away
break on the run Julius has it what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content